hey everyone matt here from code tech
tutorials
and i wanted to give you guys a little
update on where the game engine is that
i've been working on
ancient archer
is what i have
kind of code named it for now
and well last we left off
i was in code vlogs
here we have just some core base tests
and i'm just going to do a build of the
engine here
looks like everything's up to date but
we're going to just watch how fast and
see all the files by doing a rebuild
[Music]
and you can see in the list here
everything is compiling all our object
files
and it has completed now i do have an
example project here that uses the
library
the library is listed above there is aa
engine
so let's run this piece of software
and this example project is really just
me throwing some things together to make
a little first person walk around world
and just to test things out
so i was working on skeletal animations
for a while
and i'm pretty happy with where they're
at
now
so i can switch him to a different
animation
and it seems to work okay there is no
interpolating or tweening yet so they
just snapped to the next one
so that is something on the to-do list
is to be able to
morph between these animations
now the lighting is something that's
kind of hard to see in this scene
but
it was
it took some sorting out of the shaders
and i moved to an uber shader
type of deal which i will show later
[Music]
the imgui integration
definitely helps a lot
as far as testing things out
and don't mind that wall of cubes we'll
get to that later
which look like a neon wall
[Music]
so here are all the files in the project
we're looking at the example project
here and this is where i load in the
models
the large green planes are the floor
this wall of neon cubes was that wall of
neon cubes i was just testing shaders
uh with the emission and making sure
emission textures worked and as you can
see they do
but i wanted to play around with this
wall a little bit
and
i really wanted to get the physics
working on them now i can hack it but it
doesn't quite work right and the
transforms are weird
because i have different
structures of
matrices and quaternions and stuff going
between the physics
and the spatial data of my objects so
i've got to work out a few kinks there
before the physics work right and i'm
using nvidia physics
api
and what i've come to realize
is that what i really need to do is add
a proper entity component system
for all these objects in my world so i'm
doing some research on that now
and looking at
the most efficient way to do it and it
looks like i'm going to have to
restructure some of my objects
and how i've been doing things
but it should be a lot cleaner and
better in the future
because i kind of noticed as i was
adding physics that this is like way
more complicated than it should be
and the underlying reason is probably i
don't have the entity component system
so i'm just going to play around with
this wall a little bit more and i'm kind
of just i got a loop going to make a
wall here so i'm just messing with some
values
and i was uh let's see multiplying the x
and y oh i should be multiplying
something else
so it's not really doing what i expect
here i'm trying to actually get them to
separate a little bit because they look
like just one
continuous
wall here but actually they're
individual blocks
so here i have a duh moment
and realize that i should be scaling
the third variable in this function or
the third
input in this function
and i should be reducing this this down
a little bit to actually
don't we got to go less than one so
times
0.75 that's what i originally intended
i just had a one in there and there we
go
that's what we're looking for so now
when you add physics to these it should
be very obvious where they're falling
and that was where i was going here next
but
uh i've already done a bit more after
this
so maybe i'll update you guys again soon
but i think i have a pretty cool demo
coming up
[Music]
this project has moved into the private
space so i'm no longer maintaining a
public repo
if you would like access to it
going to put up a tier on
[Music]
all these things that help the channel
for source code and it's going to be a
little higher than that regular
supporter
but that'll get you access to
all this personal source code
including this uber shader that i'm
working on
yeah the whole internals so the public
one's still up it just hasn't been
updated in a while and i don't plan on
updating it but this one is my own
little uh personal thing going on here
so i'll do what i want with it but yeah
that is the state
of the engine
and where it's at it's still just a
scripting engine
where you uh make a sub project and code
it all up with c plus plus use the
library the aaa engine library
which i might change i think i'm going
to change the name to like just like
archer engine
just drop the action
we'll see though
i have another variant of this project
i have so many weird side projects well
anyways i have a variant of this that's
cmake
only no visual studio
uh
project
you could generate one with cmakeforce
but
like this one you're looking at here is
all just done in visual studio
but if this were to be cross platform
and to have a proper installer and all
that
we would want to use cmake to simplify
that or at least i would
so yeah i made another version of this
project where
it's just cmake
anyway that's another story for another
day
or for another transition
but i like to have a lot of different
things going on and always be learning
and figuring out stuff you can't stay in
one direction i feel like you got to
explore
try different things so i'm always kind
of
switching projects up as needed
but i always come back to i mean once
but here i want to add physics and get
that simulating
and i think i have to turn all that on
but also i'm pretty sure
that this isn't integrated right like as
i'm typing this up so
i'm just kind of showing that hey even
if we add
what's currently in the engine
we add those physics to each of these
cubes
and just hit go what happens
well previously there was a version
where it kind of worked but i stripped
that out because it wasn't
transforming correctly
but i think right now it's not hooked up
so there are actually physics objects in
there
but you just can't see them they're
completely invisible and they're not
changing the transforms
of the prop
as they would be expected but i need to
do
some more debugging uh it's a lot i kind
of talked about it already i basically
need to add an entity component system
and i want to get some debug draw of
these
colliders which i have mostly figured
out by now as well
but yeah we needed some kind of debug
control of the colliders to see where
they're at
we are going to want
to make some sort of front-end interface
you know like unreal or something like
that or unity but basically it'd be
doing the same thing it would just be
attaching it to yet another front end
because right now the front end is just
code and personally i like the front end
being only code i
i don't particularly like
big editors like unreal and unity and i
think a lot of us that are making our
own systems
feel that way as well
well let me know your thoughts down
below
drop your inspirational quotes
and
let me know what you're working on join
the discord the ctt discord if you want
to chat with other coders and me we're
always hanging out in there
and support the channel if you would uh
like me to keep making content and want
to see more tutorials
i have a lot of plans but i uh
been kind of struggling with the
motivation to make tutorials
and i think a lot of you kind of get why
but uh
i i do want to do it i actually recorded
one and scrapped it this here is the
physics debugger
where i was trying to see the physics
but
uh
i guess it was so small in this world
that i couldn't find it i'm pretty sure
they're out there somewhere they're just
really tiny boxes somewhere and there's
a hotkey
to snap to them but even still
i take a moment to find it here
what was i i was just saying i forget
what i was saying oh yeah about making
tutorials
it's just that
[Music]
well i have some very painful memories
of tutorials like people seem to really
like them which is cool the one that
really burns me
is this the nvidia physics tutorial like
they're all
that's a similar story that's like a
perfect case study that video took me
like
like two days to make
a lot of time way more time than you
would think
a lot of research a lot of redoing a lot
of editing
the video has made
six dollars
i've made six
dollars from that
it was
it really grinds me how much of a waste
of time it was to do that
and it just kind of blows my mind and it
like
just looking at the numbers just like
made me sit back in my seat and go whoa
what am i doing here man
this is really foolish
so
while i'd like to make more tutorials
that the reality is what i just said so
i'm basically totally relying on
community support to continue this for
real
and so every supporter means a lot thank
you all for those who have
and
yes as long as it's going i will push
out stuff i will make stuff
but jeez
i i was really just you know doing this
sort of thing is not all it's cracked up
to be like some people think you get on
youtube i mean
you make it
you get followers or whatever and
like the end goal ultimately
is to be able to make a living and doing
what you love
but the whole make a living thing
doesn't it just kind of happen it
happens to like one percent of people
and
i i think that stands pretty true
i i'm not
you know you get what you give kind of
thing so
in a lot of ways like me complaining
about the video that i just complained
about
is not even valid because who knows how
many people brought that brought in who
knows what that could lead to in the
future
there's a lot of good things that come
out of that video than just
other than just
the monetary value is what i'm saying
but none of that other stuff like pays
my rent or my bills
i can't go
to my
you know i can't go hey do you accept
like up votes on youtube videos do you
accept thanks in the comments instead of
me pain you know that doesn't work
i wish it did
i'm sure you guys do too because that's
you know free and easy
but uh
i'm basically just going on a tangent
here because
the video context was real boring there
i was basically just like
sorting out what i'm going to do with
the physics next and
i've already figured out my conclusion
which is basically to add the entity
component system
and integrate the nvidia physics more
so i'll see you guys next time peace out